[Music]
okay somebody say something this is very
very uncomfortable the first episode of
Telltale's guardians of the galaxy
series sets the action-packed sarcasm
filled stage for what's to come with
just the right amount of exposition to
keep things on track it's two hours are
paced like a movie and consistently
engaging but it's more game-like
elements of choice and exploration
remove you from the story rather than
keep you grounded in it the episode
starts strong immediately diving into
some action the Guardians get a call
from the Nova Corps who need help
fighting Santos soon enough their ship
is crashing and they stumble into battle
it might feel a little abrupt if you're
unfamiliar with guardians but bickering
among the team fills in most of the gaps
with their personalities and dynamic the
whole episode feels true to their
characters especially how they're
portrayed in the movie and it's a good
introduction to what they're all about
without relying on lengthy exposition so
many more pieces now so dramatic before
the actual fight begins though you first
find the Nova Corps completely decimated
by Thanos and you have to do some
exploring to figure things out it's the
first of several point-and-click
adventure sections that feel out of
place in the episodes movie like
structure since it's not immediately
apparent what you're looking for a
section that would take maybe a minute
in a movie can take 10 and things come
grinding to a halt it almost feels as if
your participation is just the episode
checking to make sure you're paying
attention when it was doing a fine job
of being interesting on its own the
fight itself picks things back up
switching between team members to try
and take the nose down Fitz
Telltale's quick time events style well
and it's also a critical set up for the
real conflict at the heart of the
episode rising tensions between the
Guardians most of your important
decisions revolve around siding with one
team member over another after the kind
of bonding experience only fighting a
genocide all maniac can achieve not
being able to make everyone happy is a
little heart-wrenching and those
decisions have weight to them
honestly we all stay because we you
Peter you're the one who's gonna keep us
from falling apart Wow yeah no pressure
less important dialogue choices can
reveal some backstory but a lot of them
can get confusing when star-lord has
such an established personality he's
snarky and sarcastic most of the time
but when you have options you can choose
to say something a little more mushy
about friendship and family that by
itself works fine but as the episode
goes on it can feel like you're choosing
between acting the way you think
star-lord would act and saying the
things you'd actually want to say in
certain situations it's jarring to have
choices when the decision star-lord
would make seems obvious especially
given the episodes cinematic format man
it is nice being so toward the end the
episode has one majorly important
decision but I was only able to
experience one of the two options when I
replayed it to see what would change the
only scene that was really different had
no sound it's the only bug I encountered
but its timing was more than
inconvenient even without that one seen
the episode sets up an important
conflict and serious questions about the
galaxies going into episode 2 some more
gamey elements can take you out of the
experience a bit but this is also a
compelling introduction to the series
that captures the unique charms of the
Guardians
[Music]